that love is still there 100
um i love
i love my sister britney spears is
speaking out after her sister's
emotional interview with good morning
america
on wednesday jamie lynn spears broke
down in tears talking about her older
sister whose 13-year conservatorship
came to an end in november while
promoting her new memoir things i should
have said
i've only ever loved and supported her
and done what's right by her and she
knows that so i don't know why we're in
this position right now
well on thursday brittany weighed in on
her sister's sit-down explaining to fans
on twitter that she was sick when she
watched it quote i looked at my phone
and i see that my sister did her
interview to promote her book i watched
it with a 104 degree fever lol and it
was actually kind of nice having a fever
so high because i had to surrender to
not caring i just couldn't give a [ __ ]
but my head hurts so bad
brittany also went on to reference a
specific moment from the interview where
good morning america quoted the 30 year
old's book
words that you've used in the book to
describe her behavior over that your
lifetime was
erratic paranoid
spiraling
how do you see your sister's state of
mind currently
i can't really speak to anyone else's
state of mind i don't think that's fair
well brent wasn't here for that tweeting
quote she was never around me much 15
years ago at that time so why are they
even talking about that unless she wants
to sell a book at my expense
this book isn't about me trying to clear
up anything it's about me using my voice
and showing my daughters that your voice
is important that's what this book is
about e.t sat down with a mom of two
earlier this week and she opened up
about the biggest public misconception
about her and her memoir i would hope
that people would understand that
this is a situation that's affected many
people and this is my reality that i've
grown up in it's the only reality i know
and i'm allowed to speak about that and
i think it's important to have
compassion for what we don't understand
and also make room for each and every
voice because everyone has their own
experiences and they should all be
respected and heard
by late thursday night jamie lynn saw
britney's post and responded on
instagram writing a lengthy message
addressing the 40 year old pop star
directly quote i am always here you know
behind the scenes i have always been
here jamie lynn added that it's quote
exhausting when the conversations that
they have in private don't match what
her sister posts on social media
quote i know you're going through a lot
and i never want to diminish that but i
also can't diminish myself
the former nickelodeon star concludes
her post saying that she will always
love her sister and be there for her and
as that she doesn't want any drama but
she's speaking her truth to heal her own
traumas a sentiment that echoes what she
told e.t
i think that
it's a healing process that i know that
i'm working through i can't speak for
anyone else because
each of us are in this family and we all
are dealing with things individually and
from our own
point of view so i think we have to
respect each other's process as we go
through it but it's in real time i mean
i don't have all the answers i'm just
trying to do
the best i can every day with everything
that is you know going on just like many
other families in this world
you